[Music]
and it's healthy i can't believe that
it's
this is healthy
[Music]
hey guys i'm phillip hi everyone i'm
escora
and we're making a holiday stuffing with
all fresh produce from kroger
it's going to be yummy scrummy and
nutritious
so we're going to be throwing all of
these broth ingredients straight into
the pot
three stalks of celery so celery is
something that what's the stock
oh wow is that the energy this is how
this whole thing's gonna go
stalker celery stock it's a stick of
celery
so right so three sticks it doesn't have
to be thinly chopped
same with the carrots it might feel
intimidating when you see a bunch of
different vegetables in a recipe you're
like oh this is gonna take forever
because oh
okay maybe it will take forever half
a yellow onion i definitely want you to
do this because i'm gonna ruin my
mascara
three quarters of a cup of shiitake
mushrooms
now is the seasonings that smells great
though
one tablespoon olive oil
baby do it over the pot i want them to
see
that i'm pouring it pouring it on the
kitchen counter
[Music]
[Applause]
apple cider vinegar this is a multi-use
product everything from
cleaning to washing your hair
apple cider vinegar rinse 10 to 12 cups
of water in the kitchen if you're moving
things
bring the dish to the place you're
moving never bring the dish
too he would like walk with like a
buttery wet steak
yeah across the whole thing i actually
like to drip
things all over you're not cooking
if you're not making a mess we are very
excited for the holidays because it's
our first
holidays true as a family the plan is to
just
eat as much as possible and watch as
much football football
yes that's so boring
i guess i can nap maybe while you're
doing that and that's our broth and it's
gonna simmer for
eight hours you need to draw all of the
flavors
into the broth now we're going to get
into making the stuffing
part three
tablespoons of olive oil onions are
really what
gives you the flavor oh okay do you want
to switch knives actually maybe this
one's easier ah
no right babe don't you have to look at
the onion
i'm about to be daddy where did your
finger go
you can also use a food processor i need
to go check my makeup
after that we have two sticks of celery
i'm gonna show y'all how i would do it
right let me see
i'm back oh yeah that's definitely not
diced
i just started cooking y'all so that's
what the quarantine has kind of like
taught like honestly forced me to do i
went
literally from just knowing how to
boil hot dogs
[Laughter]
to full on cooking this is
onion and garlic which smells incredible
when you start to cook it so we're gonna
put this
on and just brown it off so now we have
two stalks of celery
two large carrots here are the whole
baby bella mushrooms
it's much easier to cut a mushroom when
you've de-stalked them
these stock these are all
new words you don't have to cut them
teeny-weeny because
they reduce in size a lot now is the
seasoning
thyme parsley sage
cubes of bread stuffing is traditionally
a way to use that old style bread
really how do you like your stuffing
bigger chunks of bread
or you can get one like my mom puts it
in a blender
and that's why it's more minced so it's
up to you how
you want the texture of this because
this is your first time making stuffing
so now it's a me thing wow
this is a group project we got our bread
chunks
pressure's on because this could get
messy we've got all these
amazing fresh ingredients from kroger
and kroger has a safe way to shop you
can go
pick up or delivery so boom
broth i'm definitely gonna taste them in
a sec to make sure
top tip taste of food don't be giving
anyone food you haven't tasted first the
flavor oh i'm just hungry
do you think a little bit more salt and
pepper yeah wow this is really yummy
and the best thing when you get fresh
produce from kroger is the colors
seeing all the different colors and the
vibrancy in there makes me
so happy i'm so excited to try this
recipe
get every last drop you worked hard to
cut in all that
so i want to make sure wow look at this
all right then let's put this bad boy in
the oven gonna go in there for about 20
minutes
you've become a chef ready to die hey
yes yes
first bite kind of on a bit at the top
because it's kind of got a little bit of
a
crisp to it um
i personally love the time that's coming
up
i think that flame is really nice and
then obviously the carrot
loves me some carrot and mushrooms this
is healthy
yeah full of fresh veggies this is vegan
this is a vegan wow thank you so much
for watching our little video
using all fresh produce from kroger let
us know in the comments what you think
and we're wishing you happy holidays
[Music]
you